good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this is a man called
andrew Cuomo mr. Cuomo is the governor
of the state of New York New York is one
of the most corrupt places in the
english-speaking world you could imagine
the qualities you would need to possess
in order to run a place like that Andrew
Cuomo has those qualities and he figured
he could ride them all the way to the
White House but that didn't happen
instead another New Yorker became
president this enraged Andrew Cuomo he's
been mad ever since first year of
president Trump's administration we lost
40,000 people to gun deaths the highest
number in 50 years the unifier for the
Democrats is their anger and fear at the
Trump administration like so many people
who truly hate Donald Trump Andrew Cuomo
tumbled headlong into the rabbit warren
of russia conspiracy and in his defense
it did make it kind of sense
Trump is bad and Orange therefore he is
also a traitor who works for Putin Cuomo
made that point on Twitter quote Trump
is now aiding and abetting Vladimir
Putin a Russian dictator and trying to
cover up Russia's interference in our
elections end quote
aiding and abetting a cover-up call the
police Hodgins are here Andrew Cuomo
appeared to believe all of this and many
people did imagine how those people must
have felt yesterday for more than two
years they waited for their prosecutor
God to deliver them from their Orange
Babylon when the day finally came the
joke was on them it was all a hoax
there was no collusion Andrew Cuomo and
a lot of people like Andrew Cuomo
suddenly looked pretty stupid
luckily Andrew Cuomo knows people New
York is like that his little brother
works at CNN that's not really
surprising actually lots of people at
CNN have close ties to the Democratic
Party including the
guy who runs the place jeff zucker
hookers often said that he may run
himself for office as a Democrat so if
you want to know what Democratic Party
functionaries are thinking just flip on
CNN well last night pretty much everyone
on CNN seemed upset by the model report
andrew cuomo's little brother looked
especially agitated he'd heard people
criticizing CNN he doesn't like that it
shouldn't be allowed I'm not going to
let people say that you know CNN or the
media or whatever have been creating a
false narrative now this report is
plenty of proof that the questions that
have been asked repeatedly were legit
and if the answers we were getting
consistently were not especially once
you get past the line of hey are you a
felon once you move past that the things
they did the meetings they had that the
explanations they gave were wrong
consistently so you've got that I'm not
going to let people say CNN was wrong I
won't allow that to which you might
understandably respond who cares what
you think pal just because you're the
governor's little brother doesn't mean
you get to tell me what to say
buzz off get over yourself well okay you
could say that we're not telling you not
to say that you could ignore his orders
entirely if you wanted to it's up to you
it's your life but before you make any
hasty decisions we thought you ought to
see this you guys who are asking for the
fitness tips I'll give you one the key
to this is make sure that the dumbbells
are going to trail next to your body
like this as you go up and down you see
me coming like that I'm not doing the
exercise right
whoa
okay now ask yourself again do you
really want to criticize CNN does that
seem like a smart move this is New York
when the governor's little brother
suggests that you do something it's wise
to pay close attention if you know
what's good for you so repeat after me
CNN was never wrong CNN got it right
CNN is the most trusted name in news
good
the governor's brother likes it better
when you talk that way if only everyone
was so obedient because let's be honest
not everybody is that obedient some
people are still gonna point out that
CNN did strictly speaking
get the biggest story of the decade
completely and utterly and flamboyantly
wrong people will say that no matter how
many barbells it's anchors left because
it's undeniably true and it wasn't just
CNN virtually the entire news media did
the same thing
this was failure on an unprecedented
scale the Russia hoax wasn't simply part
of what the media covered often it was
all they covered for years the numbers
are remarkable over the first 60 days of
2018
just to pick it almost at random the
evening news shows in the broadcast
networks spent more than twice as much
time talking about the Russia hoax as
any other topic print even more profound
since the 2016 election to give you just
one measure more than a hundred and
fifty thousand Americans have died from
drug overdose
that's far more than the number of
Americans killed during the entire
second world war in the Pacific
Guadalcanal Okinawa tarah yo Jima those
battles took fewer American lives and
opioids did over an even shorter period
and yet somehow the New York Times
barely noticed any of this during the
same period that this number 150
thousand people were dying the New York
Times wrote more than twice as many
stories about the Muller investigation
that mattered more to them at the
Washington Post the ratio is even
starker last year Jeff Bezos his
newspaper ran 4319 articles about the
investigation at the same time it ran
only a little more than a thousand that
even mentioned the opioid crisis
America's shrinking middle class back
about a total of a hundred and nineteen
men mentions they they just didn't care
and they weren't pretending otherwise
they don't care cable news was as you
know even worse all Russia all the time
for years to exclusion of everything
else including obviously the truth
relentless repetitive calculatingly
dishonest the very definition of
propaganda that's what they did and now
they can't stop they've been doing it
too long watch them test-drive their new
talking point see if you can identify
which word the DNC has told them to use
the report contains a potentially
damning list of ways the president tried
to quote influence the investigation
arguing that the Muller report is far
more damning and it's not pretty it is
an ugly damning piece of business I
agree with him that it's absolutely
damning Democrats say the report is
damning report from the special counsel
is more damning than all those reports
far more damning to the president than
the Attorney General initially indicated
but it's still very Danny
I mean absolute very damning says Don
LeMond absolutely agrees the governor's
little brother and their right
it is damning